just they put in these big words into
the language to confuse everybody and
make men the bad guy what up guys
welcome to the just curly things YouTube
channel today we're going to talk about
how feminists just make up words change
definitions that mean nothing and really
are just there to confuse you so I've
done hundreds of shows with women and
men talking about relationships and
there's some words that I hear come up
over and over again and I wanted to know
what do these words mean these are just
some of the words that I've come up with
that feminists just like make up to
confuse everybody number one sexual
assault now I know there's technical
definitions that you could look up for
these things but let's just be honest
this is defined as sexual contact or
behavior that occurs without the
explicit consent to the victim so when I
hear sexual assault I think of like
something grape or something crazy easy
but now I'm finding out we can lump in
all of these sexual crimes where it's
defined on consent consent means to give
permission now on paper this sounds good
but I I think we can see how in romantic
settings this can be a bit confusing
like do you need written permission can
can it be body language like there's so
much stuff between the lines so
basically we start to lose what this
really means coercive control what the
hell does that mean coercive control gas
lighting I hear use this word
all the time oh he gaslighted me when he
would just say please don't go to the
club stop gaslighting me now I have what
trauma I am so tired of hearing about
trauma all these women have lost the
meaning of the word trauma trauma used
to mean you go to war you fight in the
war and you come back now get
cheated on one time and now they have
quote unquote trauma Financial abuse
um you can't spend five thousand dollars
on my credit card and therefore you were
financially abusing me
um emotional abuse consent because as we
said before what is consent it makes it
very broad he manipulated me what is
manipulation like it's all these words
that you hear these women say and we
don't even know what they mean genuinely
do you know what any of the means
okay no it's just they put in these big
words into the language to confuse
everybody and make men the bad guy
because all of these words where do we
hear the most demonizing men talk about
something men did men men narcissist how
is it that women are addicted to social
media yet the men are the narcissists
women are way more addicted to social
media which is very narcissistic it's me
me me me yet oh it's the men oh I dated
why does every other woman have dated a
narcissist internalized misogyny and my
my very favorite healing and I'll be
like what did you do to heal uh they
probably went to some therapist that
taught them all of these words yes
that's probably what they did so I
started to look into this stuff and I'm
just gonna use one example here here's
the thing guys us women
We Believe anything so if you start
telling us to use these words and you
start telling us that we're victims
because of all of these big words we
just start to believe it because we're
like we're like kids we just believe God
damn anything so what I found out was
what the feminists will do is they will
change the definitions of words so for
example let's talk about rape I know I
know this is a a very serious topic but
it's so serious that it's important that
we Define it the definition of rape the
carnal knowledge the sexual intercourse
of a female forcibly and against your
will okay for sex that's pretty that's
pretty clear about what that is now
today penetration no matter how slight
of the vagina or anus with any body part
or object or oral penetration by a sex
organ of another person without the
consent of the victim so they added in
all these words right to confuse you and
the ones I want you to pay attention to
penetration sex organ in and can set now
the most important one here is consent
because what is consent now let's say
you're talking to now is getting naked
consent now is is now but I'm being told
by feminists that's not consent then I
hear from feminists okay well you can
withdraw consent even during sex I'm
also told from feminists that oh oh and
and yet that you're raped that you are
raped if he takes the condom off that
that because you gave him consent with
the condom not without but we don't talk
about how women lie about being on birth
control all the goddamn time so my point
is this now we have changed the
definition of rape from forced sex to
penetration without consent where
consent is very Broad and can be
misinterpreted between party so we start
to lose the definition of very serious
crimes and they've really done it with
all of these words trauma used to be
like something that happened after War
now the feminists come in and they say
oh trauma's from cheating emotional
abuse used to be very serious now if a
guy tells you not to go to the club he's
emotionally abusing you a problem now is
that the feminists they go to the
lawmakers step one they change
definitions step two they Market the
stuff to women and they do this through
schools social media and journalists so
all of these words they change the
definition they Market it to women in
school social media and to journalists
and then we have a bunch of we have a
bunch of feminists that hate men because
they're constantly told that they're a
victim they call everything abuse sexual
assault coercive control and essentially
it's just a man-hating parade but maybe
I'm wrong I don't know let me know in
the comments if there's any words that
you think feminists have changed over
the years let me know um
what you guys want me to talk about next
time like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time